alright guys so two days ago i made a
video telling you guys not to buy
any ipad right now because we should be
expecting new ipads
in as little as one week from today
and apparently you guys really like that
video so guess what
just happened this morning the final
leak and rumor that put the last
nail in the coffin and confirmed a bunch
of other recent leaks
about apple's custom silicon max being
officially announced
in as little as six weeks from today
so what i'm gonna do in this video is
show you guys all of those leaks and
actually
wrap them all up and explain why they
totally make sense
and why we should expect these macbooks
to be announced at apple's
october event and i'm not going to stop
there i'm going to show you guys some of
the leaks of the features we should
expect
on those apple silicon macbooks but
first i want to mention that you can
find our apple silicon arm t-shirt
and our apple product mask down in the
merge shelf below
it all started at apple's wwdc 2020
event
when tim cook himself said that apple
silicon max
will begin shipping later this year so
that's confirmation from
the apple himself now on the topic of
macbooks
let me show you guys a few of the older
leaks and rumors we were seeing
a couple of months back there were some
rumors of the first apple silicon
macbook
being a revived 12-inch retina macbook
which has been discontinued for a while
now and if we consider
why it was discontinued it totally makes
sense
basically apple wanted a fanless design
but intel's chips were running way too
hot to make it a great macbook
so packing an apple silicone chip would
allow it to be much more powerful
and run cooler while still being fanless
and getting better battery life however
the very reliable analysts minsha kwo
mentioned that the 13.3 inch macbook pro
could be the very first macbook to get
apple silicon
later this year now i know a lot of you
guys are waiting for the 14 inch macbook
pro redesign
but a lot of the rumors are still
pointing to that model
coming next year so don't expect a 14
inch display
next month i personally believe that the
lower end 1300
macbook pro 13 inch is gonna get
replaced
by the new apple silicon macbook pro
while the higher end
1800 model will stay unchanged
until the 14 inch model replaces it next
year now quo
also expects a lower end 24 inch imac
to get released either at the end of
this year or early next year
but that topic is for a whole nother
video and then digitimes also mentioned
that they expect both a refreshed
macbook air and a macbook pro to get
released later this year
both with apple silicon chips so
basically
these leaks and rumors are showing us
that if you're in the market
for any lower end macbook pro from the
macbook air
to the 13-inch macbook pro you
absolutely
should not be buying one right now and
you should definitely be waiting
for apple's upcoming october event now
you're probably
asking when is that event happening and
what should we be expecting
from it and this is the part of the
video where i get into
the brand new nail in the coffin leaks
and rumors
so let's get right into it kamiya a
prominent leaker on twitter
mentioned that we should be seeing a few
things at apple's event
including a new macbook and a 13-inch
macbook pro
now as you guys can see there's no
mention of a macbook air
so let me give you guys my personal take
on this
i believe that going forward apple is
going to consolidate
the 12-inch retina macbook and the
macbook air into
one laptop and it's just going to be
called the apple
macbook why well because the current
13-inch macbook air
is already incredibly similar to the
macbook pro
the main difference is the wedge-shaped
design the intel cpu and
the cooling system and if you really
think about it
the apple silicon chip is going to
negate two of those differences
the intel cpu and the cooling system
so it just makes sense for apple to make
one simple macbook
based on a super thin design with
excellent battery life
and i'll show you guys the specific
leaks that led me to that speculation in
just a minute
but first let's get back to the date of
the apple october event
the very accurate leaker john prosser
posted an apple release date timeline
and he expects apple's iphone 12 event
to happen on the week starting october
12th
now let me first explain how apple used
to have their fall events
they usually hold an iphone event within
the first
two weeks of september and then they
hold an october event
at the end of october for ipad and mac
related things
now because of the whole pandemic
situation tim cook announced during
apple's q2 earnings results
that their iphones would be shipping a
few weeks later than usual
so that gives us confirmation that
everything should be set back
so if you look at john prosser's
timeline it totally makes sense for the
event to be moved into october
and then it also makes sense to just
consolidate both events into one
since it's going to be online only and
that makes it a bit more complicated
than usual
for apple and as for the exact date
monday the 12th of october
at 10 am pacific makes the most sense
however japanese site mac otakara
recently mentioned that the october
event could happen
in the second half of october instead so
we'll just have to wait and see
getting back to the brand new leaks
kamiya tweeted out that the 13-inch
macbook pro
will be shipping in october so i'm
expecting pre-orders to begin
on the 16th with shipments beginning on
the 23rd
and then he mentioned that the new
macbook will begin to ship in
november so this matches up to all the
leaks and rumors pointing to the macbook
pro shipping first
now as far as the features this is where
it gets very interesting
kamiya tweeted that the macbook will
have a 12 inch retina display
with an apple silicon chip getting 15 to
20 hours of battery
life that right there is the number one
reason
why this macbook will be so popular and
to make it
even better he believes the starting
price will be
849 and only
799 dollars for students and seeing as
most students will be doing their work
from home this year
apple's macbook is going to be insanely
popular
at this new low price he also mentioned
that the facetime camera will be
upgraded to 720p
from the previous 480p and it'll only be
weighing around
two pounds which is super lightweight
now you might not think he's very
credible
but earlier this morning the china times
posted an article
basically confirming everything kamiya
was saying
a very lightweight two pound macbook
with 15 to 20 hours of battery life
launching later this year and they
believe it'll come with the a14x chip
which is expected to come in the
upcoming ipad pro
but i personally believe this won't be
called the a14x
it'll be almost identical but apple will
name it something else
because apple did mention that their
apple silicon max will have
a brand new family of socs now kamiya
also tweeted out the expected features
of the macbook pro
and this is perhaps the most surprising
information
it'll have a 13-inch display which
matches up to the other rumors
but he says that it'll have the option
for either an apple silicon chip
or an intel cpu which actually isn't the
first time that i'm hearing that rumor
but maybe there's a chance that the
intel cpu option will simply be
on the higher end 1800 macbook pro which
is what i'm personally expecting
he then mentioned that it'll come with
bezels as thin as the current
16 inch model which is the very first
time that i'm hearing that
since some others have speculated that
the design will remain
unchanged but kamiyah thinks that the
body
will be a little bit smaller this year
he then mentioned that it'll get a 1080p
facetime camera
and it'll be priced at 10.99
which is 200 less expensive than the
current macbook pro
that this model will be replacing and
it's going to ship
in october so based on all of that this
will be an
absolutely killer macbook pro and due to
the price drop
many students are going to be buying
this one as well now as a final cherry
on top
he posted that in 2021 when we're
expecting the 14 inch macbook pro
he expects it to have an escape key a
new touch bar
whatever that means and a simple power
button so basically he's hinting at the
14 inch macbook pro coming with face id
built in which has been rumored for a
while now
and it's extremely exciting and i also
expect the 16-inch macbook pro to get
apple silicon next year
with face id and a new mini led display
now there are also some fresh imac
rumors as well
and i'm actually working on a video
right now where i speculate on the
design of the upcoming 24-inch imac
as well as the larger imac which is
coming next year
with a rumored custom apple gpu so if
you want to see that go ahead and click
the circle above to subscribe so you
don't miss out
and by the way check out our new apple
product mask and our apple silicon arm
shirt
down in the merch shelf below thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video